she only gives the best hugs Thanks
[Music]
what's up I'm Corbin I'm Jonah I'm
Daniel I'm Zack I'm Jack hey why don't
we and we're making a BuzzFeed quiz
today to figure out which one of us
would be your soul mate how would you
describe your style all right so Jack
you're gonna catch this first well pump
meet Obama country / like country / rap
I feel like people are gonna be really
confused when they take this quiz and
they haven't watching this video to any
family out here looking fantastic
we'll pay on your uncle's favorite
football team
Oh how'd you describe your style um
- getting tossed like a well mom she's
yet capricious facetious yet capricious
- exclamation point question number two
choose a celebrity crush
gomez should I just put that for you I
mean if you really minds Hermione
Granger Oh Amelia convey mmm
I feel like you're definitely sto your
turn now Obama Candice Swanepoel
you think that's our actual last name
Swanepoel yes yeah because I'm gonna
change it to besan all right what's one
thing you can't live with that way yak
probably my fingernails because that
would hurt if I don't have it
and it just look extremely weird I can't
live without oxygen I mean that's again
or photos that is a Corbin infinity oh
I'm going to say Hot Wheels no Club
Penguin final answer i'm final answer
and walking in and Club Penguin No Deal
I can't live without you you're a good
at this game man everyone's gonna pick
Jonah pick a night Neal date night
walking on the moon attending a spelling
bee attending a spelling bee
the day Zack spells or pronounces a word
right will be the day of the acaba lives
that's an inside joke he didn't mean to
say they might get it though I would say
probably oh gosh a helicopter ride to
the Grand Canyon and a picnic there
rinsing Atlantic Ocean my favorite song
what wdw call perfect
I'm gonna say dang I'm gonna say cheese
but I'll go with hard because it is hard
to choose what's yours - letters letters
letters we're gonna write a description
for Jack so what do you think would be a
good I got it I have noodles noodles for
I'll say noodles thick curls cuz girls
have privacy
I have curls girls oh honey the girls
get the girl have was voted sexiest man
in 1943 Oh remember that you like going
to the beach right yeah yeah excavating
and you like Rama and you really like
really okay Oh like ramen me settle for
a
okay dude what if we meet our soul mate
Norvin is your soul mate because he
created the cosmic web you love a wise
guy if you like wisdom well you like
Corbin is very straight teeth and uses
whitening strips at least once a week
he also has a smile brighter than also
than all stars that you every honest me
that's been oh I imagine to the Bing
sound actually fine then he's your man
okay is your man and you should stand oh
he's your man to stand all right that
Karen thanks yeah all it's gonna be a
second visit Gmail come hit me up I like
chicken fingers that kajol mate cuz he's
finger lickin good
because he loves chicken fingers and and
you're looking for someone who's finger
like wow you're so mate because he's a
real man because he loves coffee and
endearing and he's ready to grow old
with you
yeah now a winky winky face Wow on the
beach
I knew this kind of romantic dinners
well he like really in delivers like
Joey Joan is the one saying and we are
hey I'm trying to find find my tummy
Daniel it's about my name just Daniel is
your soulmate period so now that we
finished up you guys can take the quiz
and it's down in the description and
you'll figure out which one of us will
be your soulmate yeah good luck out
there so sad we can all live happily
ever after
yeah use your imagination I think I
think we can do this let's do it in a
one studio apartment all of us okay
No
[Music]